foreign
stop telling trans people that we're
inspirational stop telling kids to go on
your patreon and chat to you privately
without their parents knowing
[Music]
in the comments
hi kids
hey kids I want to talk to the king I
made a patreon so that we could talk
about that and this is Jeffrey Marsh's
patreon you talk about this topic
with kids now here are just some of the
signs of grooming literally one of the
first ones gaining access and isolating
the victim
asking them privately to go on patreon
[Music]
email
say income
pretty much a threat
saying I know they know where I live
and what scares me the most
is um
they have got my daughter's details on
the email
like what time I leave to drop them to
school
pick them up at some of you might know
that my car was damaged in this whole
thing
[Music]
um
a lot of people made stitches of me
saying I'm transphobic I've done a lot
of bad stuff
um they've even attacked my scarf my
religion a lot of bad stuff this creator
[Music]
I'm beautiful if you do not have a
family that loves you I'm going to be
your family I am so glad you're here I'm
Jeffrey and I am not a danger two
children
I am a danger to parents though
I'm a danger to any parent who selfishly
and egotistically insane
that a child not be themselves
foreign